the perimeter of a rectangular fence
meser measures 0.72
kilometers the length of the fenced area
is 160 meters what is its width so we
have a rectangular fence let me
rectangular fence let me draw it so that
is a rectangle you can imagine we're
looking from above this line is the top
of the fence
and if you take its perimeter the
perimeter is the distance around the
fence if you take this distance plus
this distance plus that distance plus
that distance it's going to be
0.2 kilometers that's the total distance
of all of the sides now the length of
the fenced area is 160 meters let's call
this the length so this distance right
here
this distance right here is 160
meters since it's a rectangle that
distance over there is also going to be
160 meters and we need to figure out its
width they want us to figure out the
width the width is this distance right
over here
which is also going to be this distance
right over there now what is the
perimeter of the fence the perimeter is
the sum of the this length plus this
length plus that length plus that length
so it's going to be so the perimeter let
me write it in orange the perimeter
perimeter
is going to be equal to
w
the width
plus 160 meters
plus 160
meters plus the width
plus
the width
plus 160 meters
plus 160 meters
plus 160 meters and let's assume w is in
meters so it's w
that is in
meters so we could add it all up so if
you were to add all of these up you'd
get a certain number of meters if you
were to add all of these up you have a w
plus a w so you would be 2w
2w plus 160 plus 160 is 320 so that's
so plus
320 and this whole thing is in meters
we're assuming that w is in meters now
they also told us that the perimeter of
the fence is 0.72 kilometers
so the perimeter
let me do that same orange color the
perimeter
perimeter
is also equal to
0.72
kilometers and we can abbreviate that
with k
m
now if we wanted to solve an equation if
we wanted to set this thing equal to the
total num the perimeter they gave us we
have to make sure that the units are the
same here it's in meters here it's in
kilometers so let's convert this 0.72
kilometers to meters and the way to do
that we want the kilometers in the
denominator so it cancels out with the
kilometers and you want meters in the
numerator now how many meters equal a
kilometer what's 1000
meters for every one kilometer one
kilometer is 1000 meters now if you
multiply these two things the kilometers
cancel out you're just going to be left
with the meters
and then when you multiply 0.72 times a
thousand you could just first say okay
let's take 72 times a thousand seventy
two times a thousand would be 72 with
three zeros one two three and then out
of the two numbers that you're taking
the product of we have two numbers
behind the decimal one two so you put
two numbers behind the decimal one two
right over there so zero point seven two
times a thousand is seven hundred and
twenty and that makes sense zero point
seven two it's not quite a it's not
quite one but it's getting close to one
almost three-fourths of a hole and this
is almost three-fourths of a thousand so
it makes sense so the perimeter this
information right here 0.72 kilometers
is the same thing as 720 meters
so if you take two times the width
so if you take two times the width in
meters and add that to the length and
the combined lengths it's 160 160 that's
320 and all of this is in meters
all of this is in meters
that is going to be equal to the total
perimeter which is 720 meters is equal
to
720 meters
now that we have the units right we can
solve for w and w will tell us this
within meters
in meters so 2 w plus 320 is equal to
720 we can subtract 320 from both sides
of this equation remember an equation
saying that is equal to that if we want
them both always to be equal whatever we
do the left-hand side we have to do the
right-hand side
so we subtract 320 from both sides
subtract 320 from both sides
the left-hand side that cancels out
that's why we subtracted 320 and you
just you just have left two times the
width is equal to 720 minus 320 is 400
now you can divide both sides of this by
two
divide both sides by 2
and then you're left with w is equal to
400 over 2 which is 200 which is 200 and
we said that w was in meters so the
width is 200
the width is 200 meters so this is 200
meters this is 200 meters and let's see
if it makes sense 200 plus 200 is 400
plus 320 is 720 so the total perimeter
is 720 meters which is the exact same
thing as 0.72 kilometers